kinder stinging oh yeah this first one
comes from Cody from Myrtle Beach how
there's Brendan that's me and you Tigers
god damn that is a big time that's da
camels son dude
yeah that's da kennels son right there
Cody annal the tiger Whisperer himself
can you imagine no I can't nope not for
me that's you and your son dude years
from there years ago years from now that
could easily lead from your book Cody
antle's killing it 1.9 million videos of
him the other day like basically playing
tic-tac-toe or something with a mountain
lion it's unbelievable the stuff he's
able to do look at that man look at that
Oh has he never had didn't ditch guys
talk to him did eat I haven't even been
bit by these Tigers and [ __ ]
doc and his son have never been big
maybe yeah they said they've been kind
of like jostle around but never bit he
said they got to do yoga almost every
day in order for their bodies to be able
to like handle the weight of when these
animals come on come at him you know
relax but look at him though relax he's
agile
Brennan that's called a John oh yeah for
sure you got to know about this yeah you
gotta be pretty flexible to [ __ ] with
his Tigers I mean what did he just I
asked us I can't even be friends with
start your Tigers King understand I like
to look at him would you get in there
it's kind of like being a friends with
Theo gotta be careful man he's good in
doses I'll say that Oh Vinny then he
gets dark you know second dude look I
start I start with a small ground game
maybe you know that that the baby hits
yeah dude them wrong all King yeah I
guess I don't know like would you go
there and hang out with these Tigers I
would we don't know him very well yeah
agreed but so we're just gonna risk our
lives Mike yeah let's go hang out with
this [ __ ] tiger I'm not gonna need em
up with like homegirl
who's clearly in the chicks that lost
their [ __ ] arm yeah which probably
helps her to hook up with them girls
didn't you get that conversation started
oh sure you got that knob yeah dude when
you got that old that you know when you
missing a [ __ ] turn signal bro that's
a conversation drive yeah yeah oh my
buddy stuff about like a cutoff arm
something and he would hide behind a
counter and he would call is 45 well
that's sad now that's sad but damn
watching him submarine around behind the
bar he get behind the bar and just like
it was like I bet he got a lot of chicks
doing that I don't know heated up with
someone I do know that though but uh
what is that a submarine oh my god let
me drink da cantle did invite us out all
out to his twenty two person mansion
where you can sleep with monkeys and
elephants and tigers so if we want to do
a little road trip and you said like
would you go there with all the
creepiness I mean there's too much heat
Adam there they're gonna be chill now
they need good PR we're creepy oh I
don't think he's creepy I just don't
trust these [ __ ] Tigers yeah I trust
doc and his son they're cool I don't
trust Tigers that are [ __ ] I'm not
trying to also I don't sleep with a
tiger why I'm allergic to cat are you
really yeah
this ain't no cat [ __ ] that's
exactly what nah dude you're allergic to
little [ __ ] ass casts that eat out of a
can bruh this is a real ass annum he's a
hottie too [ __ ] bedroom mansion in
Florida said 22 persons so probably I
don't know Undertaker was just there
last week
doing what try not to dive just some
good PR I'm gonna say King in on the
Tigers man I say this if you got if you
die getting mauled I think that's the
way to go man old school bet get back to
the earth quicker get back to the Lord I
think if you're out here just you know
yeah you allergic to some [ __ ] little
cat knee
Rony or something like that brah how's
that dude yeah I'll [ __ ] that man I'm
trying to live I don't trust these
Tigers I don't know them
I'm good what what's the best-case
scenario I'm on the ground with a
[ __ ] Tiger worst case hey it's high
gur it's not worth it man I think that
that's that that that's the chance you
take man to be engaging with your unique
animals dude now what you gonna spend
your whole life just touch them [ __ ]
easy ass animals bro reach for the stars
do know I'm down to go to Africa and see
one in the wild
what's that real hitter that organic
Tiger hitters [ __ ] yeah I know so all
those [ __ ] Florida [ __ ] you look
like beef jerk bro
nothing's gonna see you you want to go
walk around I'm not walking bro I'm in a
safari you wouldn't want to do Kingdom
harvesting wild and you'll do a safari
in Africa I wouldn't I would his way
weather right over to South Carolina and
practice safari firsthand the safe
comfortable confines of somebody's
living room where they got blow dart
guns and a dude over there who's you
know able to probably put a bomb and the
thing and if it goes off they set off
the bomb you know they'd be right
it's just not for me I'm not trying to
ride over to Africa dude and take my
chances out there they'll kill you in a
heartbeat
hanging out with Undertaker who's 90
years old and his [ __ ] old lady and a
tiger safe yeah in the pool yeah dude
you got your goddamn mind coming from
the other [ __ ] in the pool as a child
dude you don't even how to operate in
these areas yeah you're right
what else you got Nick I'm gonna king
tigers but I'm gonna sting hanging out
with them all right then I'll go in I'll
hang out with them what are you gonna do
stand on the side and what you face you
face time no you feel I'll be outside
the door in your face I want to be in
there I'll hunt a boar dude I've said
this for years people out there shooting
a boar from 2,000 yards give me a knife
I'll cut that fat thing's [ __ ] nose
on about
let's get a board on the killer's back
killer B's back I say let's get two
knives and let's go work up their noses
off dude that's what I'm saying I think
it's fair if you get out there and you
hunt something straight up me too yeah
no guns no heat-seeking missile just
this thing in a [ __ ] night yeah doing
a positive attitude twice stabbing on
the third one [ __ ] yeah I'll be down for
that all right dude I like it man gang
[Music]